comment on arrive à faire en sorte qu'il
y ait des jeunes qui qui qui viennent
s'installer dans le métiers c'est pour
ça que d'abord il faut qu'on ait un
discours aussi positif c'està dire que
on a connu des crises on va arriver àer
surmonter il y a un enjeu principal qui
est celui de la préservation de la
biodiversité et la transition
énergétique pour et bien avoir cette
souveraineté aussi de de nos flottes et
et moi je j'ai vraiment en allant dans
tous les lycées maritims on a des jeunes
quit envie de s'installer qui ont envie
de faire des pêches qui sont différentes
de ce qui pouvit être pratiqué par leurs
aînés mais qui ont envie de faire qui on
envie de participer aussi et bien à à
l'activité économique de leur pays il y
a plus plusieurs Levi au-delà de ce que
vous avez dit sur la transition
énergétique à juste titre enfin au-delà
de ce que vous avez dit pardon sur la
formation 1 il y a bien évidemment des
bateau qui soit plus moderne plus neuf
enfin c'està dire rien que d'avoir quand
vous sortez à la mer une semaine ou voir
3 jours d'avoir des espacces de
convivialité c'est évident que peut-être
qu'il y a 20 30 ans c'était accepté ou
acceptable maintenant les jeunes ils ont
le choix entre plusieurs métiers ils
vont vite choisir donc ça c'est un
élément très important sur la
modernisation des navires des navires
moins bruillants et des navires qui
respectent beaucoup plus fortement
l'environnement ça ça c'est une demande
et c'est ce qu'on va faire avec ce plan
de transition énergétique de 450
millions d'euros deux sur les aides à
l'installation là c'est dans le cadre du
féempa donc ils sont à la main des
régions il y a des aides à
l'installation possibles il y a des
aides à l'installation possible donc il
y a des régions qui le font d'autres qui
commencent à le faire et c'est vrai que
peut-être que l'enjeu de l'installation
était moins vrai il y a 20 ans
maintenant c'est un enjeu principal et
donc on travaille bien évidemment avec
les régions pour essayer de bien
calibrer et tout ça pour faire en sorte
qu'il y ait aussi et bien cet
inconvignant ce cou de pouce ceou de
pouce ce coup de pouce pardon pour nos
jeunes ensuite et c'est lié à la
question de Madame Olivier c'est la
question aussi et bien dans les OP ou
dans la répartition des quotas d'avoir
et bien au-delà des critères sociaux et
environnementaux des critères sur ben je
sais pas c'est l'âge mais en tout cas
faire en sorte que on puisse en en
attribuer à des plus jeunes c'est ce que
nous nous avons fait avec notamment dans
le cadre du PAI en disant qu'il faut et
bien que on puisse donner la possibilité
à des jeunes qui n'ont pas de côtin de
pouvoir s'installer et donc c'est ce que
nous faisons avec la réserve qui est
issue euh du plan d'accompagnement
individuel ce qui leur donne des
capacités de pêcher des capacités euh de
euh produire et puis c'est aussi les
accompagner avec des aides privées c'est
ce que fait cm acgm avec ces 20 millions
d'euros qui viennent euh et bien
faciliter accompagner des projets
novateurs des projets qui visent à
expérimenter des choses et ce qu'on
envie aussi de faire nos jeunes
c'est-à-dire de d'essayer de de tester
aussi des modèles de pêche des types de
pêchees qui sont peut-être un peu
différentes de leurs aînés donc il faut
leur render les moyens et ce fonc m acgm
leur permettra de le faire